من بين اسلافه الاربعين كان اطوالهم
انتظارا لمده تقارب 70 عاما ظلت تشارلز
ولي للعهد قبل ان ياتي اوان حكمه عين في
المنصب وهو ابن ثلاث سنوات بعد وفاه جده
الملك جورج السادس وتولي والدته اليزابيث
الثانيه الحكم عاش طفوله فرضتها ظروف
العائله الملكيه حيث درس سنواته الاولى في
نظام تعليمي خاص في قصر باكينغهام في لندن
الى ان قررت الملكه الحاقه بمدرسه عامه
وفيها اكمل مشواره الدراسي ويعد اول فرد
في سلاله وينزر العائله الملكيه
البريطانيه يحصل على شهاده البكالوريوس
درس الاداب وعلوم الاثار والانتروبولوجيا
ثم غير تخصصه الى التاريخ والتحق بعدها
بكليه القوات الجويه الملكيه والكليه
البحريه الملكيه في دارتموث حصل على لقب
فارس في سن الثلاثين ويحمل الملك تشارلز
الثالث رتبه الماريشال في الجيش البريطاني
وفي القوات الجويه الملكيه وهي اعلى رتبه
في القوات المسلحه البريطانيه لغير
البريطانيين ومواطني دول الكوميز كانت
تشارلز امير ويلز ولي العهد حينها شخصيه
غير معروفه لكن هذا سيتغير مع زواجه من
الاميره ديانا فرانسيس بنسر صيفه 81 من
القرن الماضي فيما عرف حينها بزواج القرن
زواج امتد لتسع سنوات ولد خلاله الاميران
ويليام ولي العهد الحالي والامير هنري
المعروف بهاري والذي قرر الانفصال عن
التاج البريطاني بعد زواجه بالممثلات
الامريكيه
زواج الامير تشارلز والاميره ديانا كما
بدا بصخب عالمي انتهى بدجه اكبر واثار
امداد الصحافه وحاز اهتمام العالم لما كان
فيه من دراما واشاعات واتهامات بالخيانه
الزوجيه وخلفت وفاه الاميره ديانا في حادث
سير في باريس سنه 97 من القرن الماضي
اثارا سلبيه على الاسره الملكيه وعلى
الامير تشارلز شخصيا في ابريل من سنه 2005
تزوج الامير تشارلز الدوخه كامله في حفل
مدني بوينزور جالهول بعد علاقه جمعتهما
لفتره طويله حمل تشارلز القابل كثيره منها
وهو لقب حصل عليه في سن الرابعه بعد وفاه
جده الملك جورج السادس عام
1952 اسس اكثر من سته عشره جمعيه خيريه
اهتماما خاصا لقضيه التغير المناخي وصنفت
مجله تايم الامريكيه سنه 2007 كاحد ابطال
البيئه